the art world witnessed history this
week when the Peggy and David
Rockefeller collection scored a record
some at auction christie's sold 1500
items from the estate including
paintings by some of the most well known
artists of the past 200 years everything
sold all the proceeds go to charity the
final total eight hundred and thirty two
million dollars what's in a name well if
it's rockefeller apparently a lot the
auction this week of the estate of David
and Peggy Rockefeller brought three days
of bidding that literally took people's
breath away sixty-eight million the
first night this Picasso sold for a
hundred and fifteen million dollars this
Matisse 80 million this Monet nearly
eighty five million by the end of that
first session Christie's Jessica fertig
said we have already broken the record
for any collection sales the frenzy
continued on night - when gilbert
stuart's renowned portrait of george
washington was on the block at nine
hundred and fifty thousand 1 million
dollars now 1 million 100,000 it's
soared past its 1.2 million dollar
estimate the final price 11.5 million
ten times the estimate was a record for
the artist when we previewed the sales
last weekend with christie's market
porter he showed us a dessert service
made for Napoli's and this is Napoleon's
ice cream bowl basically it is his ice
cream bowl estimated at 250,000 dollars
it's sold for 1.8 million even the
relatively inexpensive items went for
staggering prices a picnic basket given
to david rockefeller by the king of
morocco estimate $1,200 brought two
hundred and twelve thousand so how far
back in family history would some of
these go and the family's old spider
fightin carriage that David Rockefeller
jr. showed us fetched two hundred and
twenty-five thousand finally there was
the rockefeller
sent her money clip with a modest
estimate of $1,200 he'd attracted a lot
of attention this may be my favorite
thing in the auction along with many
other people I think what better to hold
a stack of bills
turns out you needed a stack of bills
just to buy it
sale price seventy five thousand dollars
it's you know when you look at like the
Napoleon desert service and you go how
can that go for 1.8 million dollars well
it can because the two owners have been
Napoleon and the Rockefellers right you
don't get to bigger names right it just
makes me wonder what was there that was
possibly affordable not much but you
know the good news in all this eight
hundred and twenty million dollars to
charity
yeah definitely great